Шановні колеги фракція європейської
солідарності буде підтримувати про як
закону про ратифікацію додаткового
протоколу до конвенції Ради Європи про
запобігання тероризму очевидно що це
рішення для нас для України особливо
актуальне через те що нам доводиться
сьогодні протистояти державі терористу
Російській Федерації додатковому цьому
протоколі до конвенції надаються важливі
визначення зокрема участі у
терористичній організації і групі
навчання тероризму його фінансування і
також Зверніть увагу що цей додаток
передбачає обмін інформацією з державами
учасницями конвенції через контактні
групи які мають діяти цілодобово і в
нашому випадку це СБУ в цьому
конкретному
розрізі хотіла б звернути увагу на
наступне два місяці в країні яка веде
війну і змушена
протидіяти державі терористу терористу
немає Голови служби безпеки України
причому попередній Голова служби безпеки
України був звільнений за статтею щодо
дій які понесли за собою людські жертви
Я сподіваюся що парламент України
ратифікувавши цю конвенцію також
застосуємо всі механізми парламентського
контролю для того щоб пересвідчитися що
СБУ має усі інструменти для введення цих
контактів зі своїми партнерами і щодо
тої інформації яка є секретною не будуть
мати доступу
криси і щурі якими все ще напічкані наші
окремі спецслужби дякую